es gibt aktuell eine wichtige diskussion
in deutschland nämlich unser
bundesgesundheitsminister möchte die
regelung zur organspende ändern
was bedeutet das genau es ist gut dass
ihr hier seid nehmt euch ein bisschen
zeit denn egal ob er jetzt organe
spenden möchte oder auch nichts es ist
wichtig dass ihr euch auskennt denn nur
ihr könnt über euren eigenen körper
entscheiden
nur was ist die richtige entscheidung
das klären wir jetzt eins ist sicher wir
werden alle sterben super einstieg und
egal ob wir jung oder alt sterben unsere
organe könnten nach unserem tod
verhindern dass andere menschen sterben
müssen wenn ich also organspender bin
erkläre ich mich jetzt zu lebzeiten dazu
bereit dass nach meinem tod organe oder
gewebe entnommen werden dürfen also mein
herz könnte nach meinem tod in der brust
eines anderen menschen weiter schlagen
und dieser mensch hätte auch außer
dieser organspende derzeit keine andere
alternative zum überleben das bedeutet
organspende rettet leben
und derzeit warten in deutschland über
10.000 menschen auf ein spenderorgan
doch wir haben nicht genügend
organspender um die zahl sinkt auch noch
und das ist ein problem nun gibt es
nachvollziehbare gründe keine organe
spenden zu wollen manche menschen finden
ihr körper ist nun einfach mal kein
ersatzteillager das ist ein legitimer
gedanke und jetzt nicht mein körper
gehört mir allein
ich darf darüber entscheiden manche
menschen trauen der organspende einfach
nicht so recht viele erinnern sich noch
an den transplantation skandal 2012 da
gab es einen leitenden arzt an der
uniklinik göttingen
der hatte krankenakten und wartelisten
verfälscht damit manche menschen die auf
ein organ warten schneller an dieses
organ com und andere in der warteliste
runterrutschen was natürlich leben
kosten kann und auch in anderen
krankenhäusern wurden danach ähnliche
manipulations fälle bekannt nach diesem
skandal wurden die regeln und kontrollen
auch verschärft um zu vermeiden dass so
etwas in zukunft noch mal passieren kann
doch das misstrauen blieb allerdings
zeigt uns dieser transplantation skandal
auch ein großer teil des problems liegt
darin dass zu viele menschen auf zu
wenige spender
organe war das schädlich an dem skandal
war sicher auch dass ich menschen
gefragt haben kann nicht ärzte überhaupt
noch vertrauen also nicht nur als
patient der auf ein spenderorgan warten
sondern auch als jemand der bereit ist
organe zu spenden angst vor organspende
viele haben folgende angst nämlich wenn
ich jetzt mich bereit erkläre organe zu
spenden werde ich dann schneller und
bereitwilliger für tot erklärt wenn mir
was passiert oder werden lebensrettende
behandlungen vielleicht abgebrochen
damit man schneller an meine organe
kommt das ist für nachvollziehbarer
weise die häufigste angst die menschen
haben die ihm keine organe spenden
möchten
doch diese angst muss man in deutschland
nicht haben die medizinische
voraussetzung für eine organspende
hierzulande dürfen organe nur entnommen
werden wenn zwei unabhängige ärzte
zweifelsfrei den sogenannten hirntod
feststellen können und was das genau
bedeutet dazu komme ich auch gleich noch
nur das führt dazu dass ist genau
andersrum ist das heißt anstatt dass
menschen vorschnell zur organspende
herangezogen werden passiert in der
praxis genau das gegenteil weil die
anforderungen an diese hirntod diagnose
so hoch sind fallen viele potenzielle
organspender weg dienen dürfen gar keine
organe entnommen werden weil viele
krankenhäuser nicht das fachpersonal
haben um diesen hirntod festzustellen
dass muss man hier schon dazu sagen das
problem ist nicht nur dass wir nicht
genügend organspender haben in
deutschland sondern dass unsere
krankenhäuser eben nicht die möglichkeit
haben diesen tieren tod zweifelsfrei
festzustellen
und auch dann dürfen eben keine organe
entnommen werden falls ihr immer noch
beunruhigt seit die medizinischen
richtlinien wurden 2015 auch noch mal
verschärft und die hirntod diagnose dies
wissenschaftlich unumstritten also
verifizierung dazu findet ihr auch in
der video beschreibung nur was heißt
jetzt hier in tod genau beim hirntod
handelt es sich um einen irreversiblen
dass es nicht umkehrbaren ausfall des
gehirns diese todesart ist aber recht
selten meistens haben wir tod durch
herzstillstand
und dann dürfen in deutschland keine
organe entnommen werden das heißt die
meisten menschen kommen als organspender
ohnehin nicht in frage darf man ihren
tod auch der herzstillstand folgt und
dann auch irgendwann die organe kaputt
gehen würden also auch nicht mehr
brauchbar wären für eine transplantation
werden hier ein tote wenn sie denn
organspender sind künstlich beatmet dh
das herz schlägt auch noch der tote ist
warm
das kann für die angehörigen ziemlich
heftig und belastend sein also es hat
aber mit dem cobra oder so nichts zu tun
man ist unwiederbringlich tot
das waren jetzt die medizinischen
voraussetzungen für eine organspende die
angst dass organspender früher für tot
erklärt werden oder schlecht behandelt
werden ist in deutschland unbegründet
und die hier tut diagnose ist
wissenschaftlich unstrittig dann kann
man sich ja fragen organspende rette
leben warum macht man organspende nicht
einfach zur pflicht wenn wir doch zu
wenige spender haben na ja auch wenn es
keine rationalen gründe gibt keine
organe zu spenden
tod und trauer sind ja nicht rational
vielleicht möchte ich einfach nicht ohne
herz zum beispiel im sarg liegen ich
brauche das jetzt zwar nicht mehr aber
das kann trotzdem viele nachvollziehen
oder wir haben bei quarks eine ganze
sendung zur organspende gemacht
verlinkte ich euch unten auch in einer
stelle ging es auch um die angehörigen
und genau darum wie krass ist wenn da
ein geliebter mensch liegt der zwar tot
ist das weißt du vielleicht rational
aber der mensch liegt hat das war der
atmet das herz schlägt eine mutter die
ihren sohn zur organspende freigegeben
hat hat es im nachhinein so formuliert
dass sie sagt mir wurde sozusagen die
erfahrung des todes genommen
sie sagt das letzte bild das ich von
meinem von meinem kind habe ist das
eines atmenden kindes und das macht es
sehr viel schwerer den abschied die man
einfach nehmen muss dann auch wirklich
zu gehen aber vor allem wäre eine
pflicht zur organspende völlig
inakzeptabel weil euer körper euch
alleine gehört und nur ihr alleine
darüber entscheiden dürfte auch nach
ihrem tod damit kommen wir jetzt zu den
relevanten teil nämlich zur entscheidung
auf die entscheidung kommt es an in
deutschland ist die regelung derzeit
folgendermaßen im normalzustand also per
default ist erstmal keine organspende
nur wenn ich ausdrücklich zustimmen zum
beispiel auf einem organspendeausweis
dürfen wir nach dem tod organe entnommen
werden
unter den genannten voraussetzungen in
anderen ländern hingegen gibt es die
sogenannte widerspruchslösung das heißt
katie fforde ist erstmal jeder
organspender
es sei denn ich widerspreche
ausdrücklich übrigens kann man auch auf
dem organspendeausweis widersprechen das
wissen viele gar nicht also dieses ding
heißt nicht ja ich bin organspende
dieses ding heißt lediglich ja ich habe
mich entschieden also genau genommen
soll in deutschland eine doppelte
widerspruchslösung eingeführt werden das
bedeutet ich bin automatisch
organspender es sei denn ich
widerspreche oder meine angehörigen
widersprechen nach meinem tod deshalb
doppelt so das interessante ist jetzt
egal welche regelung gilt in jedem fall
darf ich frei entscheiden
deswegen warum diskutiert man überhaupt
so groß darüber weil der default also
der normalzustand einen großen einfluss
hat sehr viele menschen vier bleiben
einfach im default modus als im
normalzustand weil sie schlicht und
einfach zu träge sind um sich darum zu
kümmern
also hat keine zeit sich die
informationen einzuholen oder einfach
keine lust über den tod nachzudenken
also alles nur verständlich
und weil auch viele menschen schlecht
informiert sind empfindet man den
default also den normalzustand als
offizielle empfehlung und bleibt
deswegen einfach dabei der default
beeinflusst also die entscheidung der
menschen und deshalb gibt es in ländern
mit widerspruchslösung deutlich mehr
organspender bei unseren nachbarn in
österreich herscht die
widerspruchslösung und die haben
prozentual zweieinhalb mal mehr
organspender als ihr in deutschland in
spanien gibt es anteilig fast fünfmal so
viele organspender und das liegt nicht
nur aber auch an der widerspruchslösung
ich persönlich bin eher für die
widerspruchslösung weil wir aus umfragen
wissen dass sehr viele menschen in
deutschland organspende positiv sehen
und es zumindest deutlich mehr spender
geben müsste als derzeit der fall ist es
gibt aber auch gute gründe gegen eine
widerspruchslösung zum beispiel kann man
argumentieren man darf halt einfach
nicht mit dem körper eines anderen
irgendetwas machen ohne dessen
zustimmung deswegen ist es nur richtig
dass man ausdrücklich zustimmen muss
doch eigentlich müssten wir gar nicht
darüber diskutieren wenn wir es
stattdessen irgendwie schaffen würden
das sich wirklich jeder damit
auseinandersetzt und sich wirklich jeder
entscheidet denn wer sich jeder
entscheiden würde dann hätten wir
bereits viel mehr potenzielle
organspender und eine wichtige sache
darf man auch nicht vergessen in
deutschland wir hatten auch immer die
angehörigen gefragt vermittelt ist der
patientenwille das entscheidende aber
wenn es in der familie differenzen gibt
und angehörige sind dagegen
dann würde man nie um jeden preis der
organspende durchziehen
im idealfall ist es natürlich so dass
man sich in der familie damit befasst
mit der thematik und die nächsten
familienangehörigen wissen wie der
patienten entschieden hätte
und auch diesen wunsch respektieren dann
gibt es am wenigsten reibungspunkte und
wenn man sich zu lebzeiten nicht mit dem
thema auseinandergesetzt hat dann
überträgt man diese schwere entscheidung
auf seine liebsten und die wollte ich
jetzt nicht nach meinem tod auch noch
damit belassen wir halten fest
in deutschland gibt es zu wenig
organspender und ihr braucht eure organe
nach dem ton nicht mehr wenn die organe
spenden möchte dann haltet das fest und
auch wenn ihr nicht spenden möchte und
das ist völlig okay dann haltet das auch
fest wo man so ein organspendeausweis
bekommt das findet ihr in der video
beschreibung zum beispiel kann man
dieses ding online ausfüllen und sich zu
hause ausdrucken und was auch
funktioniert das wissen viele gar nicht
man kann auch einfach einen zettel mit
den entsprechenden infos unterschreiben
und sich den geldbeutel legen das
funktioniert genauso man kann auch nur
ein bestimmtes organ spenden oder
bestimmte organe ausschließen
prinzipiell kann man folgende organe
spenden das könnt ihr euch nochmal in
der video beschreibung durchlesen oder
hier mal kurz pausieren es gibt keinen
wissenschaftlichen medizinischen oder
wenn man so wie rationalen grund dafür
bestimmte gewebe nicht zu spenden das
ist auch wir einfach teil eurer
entscheidungsfreiheit über euren körper
was viele organspender tatsächlich
hinschreiben ist ich spende alles außer
meine augen ist auch interessant oder
den ist natürlich auch klar dass sie
ihre augen nicht mehr brauchen nach dem
tod aber man hat dann doch irgendwie so
ein emotionales verhältnis zu seinem
körper und für die kann man vielleicht
noch sagen dass die augen so sowieso
nicht entnommen werden also man muss
sich zumindest keine sorgen machen dass
man ohne augen oder mit eingefallenen
augenhöhlen dann im sarg liegt sind von
den augen werden wie gesagt nur hornhaut
oder lederhaut ich habe einen
organspendeausweis also einen
ausgefüllten und was er genau drauf
steht ist völlig irrelevant für euch
denn das ist eine persönliche
entscheidung ich will euch mit diesem
video keine bestimmte entscheidung
empfehlen sondern ich möchte euch nur
bitten euch zu entscheiden
denn das ist die hauptsache zu einer
guten entscheidung gehört natürlich dass
man sich auskennt und deswegen hoffe ich
dass dieses video euch helfen konnte und
falls sie doch noch offene fragen haben
solltet dann schaut man in die video
beschreibung hab ich euch verlässliche
infos verlinkt und zum beispiel auch wie
gesagt meine sendung zu dem thema
letztes jahr habe ich mit die debatte
das thema auch behandelt findet ihr wie
gesagt alles unten
ansonsten sehen wir uns nächste woche
oder in den kommentaren
bis dahin bleibt sicher